imagine I know hi there I just wanted to
report a
incident
yeah well it is kind of an emergency to
me because the fingers my what my life
is kind of ending in danger in a way
because I wish I was basing my life is
kind of in danger a bit because I've
been accused
he was basically insinuating that my
involvement in the Manchester attacks
and the thing of this is this has caused
people to think that I'm involved and
send me death threats so I want yes
basically he's a public figure I don't
know if you know him I'm sure a lot of
people know him he's a far-right group
of individual he's basically insinuated
that he bought my mom a YouTube I'm a
Muslim youtuber my name is Ali Dawa and
I'm I'm a Muslim YouTube I do YouTube
videos so I do like you yes all she
experiments and stuff like that yeah
yeah
and then basically he put a tweet saying
jihadi Ali da WA and he was saying some
statements and he was basically using a
video of mine a couple of months ago
that's but nothing to do with anything
me telling people to not go to Drake's
concert for some other specific reasons
[Applause]
this tweet was two days ago he said
jihadi Ali da WA and his group calling
on Muslims in Manchester not to attend
music concerts Drake and Arianna UK so
basically what he's trying to make cuz
this was a video done a couple of months
ago where Drake rapper he basically
called out a Muslim in the audience and
if the videos enough to do anything but
more he was insinuating is that we had
pre we had we've known that the attacks
are gonna happen
and we was basically telling Muslims to
not go there
so he's insinuating that I had an idea I
knew this was happening so if I know
that means I was involved in it and then
you've got people commenting like this
fool Ali once and terrorize and kill
others for not doing so you can send
someone no I'm in a different address
though yeah I would appreciate if you
can do that okay do they say when
they're gonna be carried out not really
but is it more is it more than one
suspect there's one here saying I will
shoot this filthy mix if I ever had the
chance
right yeah yeah you haven't even like a
specific time yeah but do you find that
you must call us true we're not there
yet
okay few more they smell but our way for
the police to come then they're gonna be
won't get so much you know yeah they
should be ready within the hour
okay okay serious threat and I'm Balika
what I mentally better care to brothers
and sisters in the offense hope you guys
are doing well may Allah bless every
single one of you guys and if your
non-muslim welcome to my channel do
check out my other videos and understand
and know the true form of Islam as you
guys know a couple of days ago a tragic
event happen in Manchester and these
tragic terror of ends happen all over
the world wherever it may be
it made me Syria it may be Iraq it might
it may be Iran it might be Brazil
whatever it may be terror attacks or
terror attacks and these are carried out
by individuals by different names some
people come some people do it in the
name of Christianity something do in the
name of Islam so I'm doing the name of
far-right groups you know like those who
are involved with Tommy Robertson and
Britain first etc some do it in the name
of this politician that political group
whatever it may be so these terror
attacks are happening all over the place
now when we act as if terror attacks are
only happening by Muslims then we can
say okay you know what maybe there's a
problem why is it every single terror
attacks no other terror organization
that a non-muslim does it but only
Muslims then we can worry and think okay
there's something wrong with Islam
however terror attacks like a few a week
ago a man drove into a crowd yes his
terror attack what was it to blame drugs
so what we're trying to say here is that
terror attacks happen and innocent
people are being killed now the question
that least II asked here is this does
Islam promote violence that's Islam
promote the killing of innocent people
I've challenged before I've set this
challenge in front of say again I
challenge anyone specific especially
Tommy Robinson and I've wanted to meet
him so many times but he doesn't he
ignores much when they meet and talk to
him a simple question I want to ask can
you please show me anywhere anywhere in
Islamic circles the Quran the hadith
lets up see whatever it may be that
orders asked and go and kill innocent
people
please I am really asking for this you
know and recently he did a tweet on his
Twitter calling me jihadi an accusation
a stand
a lie which I'm sure a lot of people he
had a backlash people saying you are
lying and he put a video of me three
months ago about a Drake concert where
Drake said something to a Muslim girl
which I found a bit it's time of phobic
and I just said something about it
and he's using that to insinuate that I
had some connections with the Manchester
events and that I told people hey don't
go now this is a big accusation and
people have given deference to me as you
can see on the screen people are saying
we should do that to him he putting my
life in danger over a life you know so
besides the point now as a person what
like I said before I'm going to report
this because this is an act of terrorism
this is a this is you are insinuating
that I was involved in hate speech you
know and what you're doing is you are
actually the acid tube if I always say
you have no different to Isis you and
Isis are the same thing the only thing
is Isis what they do is they carry out
the attacks you if you have the chance
you would kill Muslims I believe if you
had the chance you will actually attack
and kill Moses you know why because you
insinuate that you're pushing people to
take action against Muslims you know so
what's that gonna do if my life is in
danger is because of you just the way
Isis propagates to naive individuals
most Muslims here who don't know much
about that about their religion and they
incinerate these people to attack
innocent people and you're doing the
same thing as Isis does so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna bring the
Metropolitan Police Terrorism right now
in front of you guys and report this
incident and I want you guys to do the
same and report this incident of Tom
McDonald Robinson accusing me of being
connected with Manchester that's what a
disgusting thing to do what a disgusting
thing to say you know I'm a normal
Muslim I go about my life you know I
like to do fun things sometimes I go
Dubai I have fun I go do the normal
things I work I earn money you know I
look after my family you know accession
I have a wife I have a family just do
what you do why is it if my religion
teaches me to do this I'm an awful rocks
Muslim why is it that I don't go and
start doing the same things
why if we're gonna say that Mugen this
was mathematics tell me if you have a
brain if you have you can use
mathematics to feel good at maths even
need to be good at maths you really
don't need to be good at maths
let's get this right you say Islam
creates terrorism yeah this is terrorism
and you're going based on 0.00001
percent of the population of Muslims who
are tiny circle this accent let's
suppose it's even more or less than that
if we're going to equate the terrorism
based on that we have more of
right to equate Islam with peace because
99.999999 percent of Muslims don't carry
out these attacks or get involved in
such things
so that is absolutely rubbish and once
again and in the meantime to me I am
looking forward to meet you I am
literally a car when today to actually
meet you you know so if you can please
that's arranged let's talk I just want
to sit down and talk you know hopefully
and we can see you know your challenge
my challenge is anywhere show me
anywhere and you can do your homework
any way that tells Muslims to kill
innocent people
please please are really ugly too